effectivement en effectivement sérénité
je voudrais interroger madame la
Première ministre sur une préoccupation
majeure des Français semaines et
semaines madame la Première ministre
notre pays sur laborieusement de la
pénurie de carburant que les Français
vivent depuis plusieurs semaines et
aujourd'hui encore une station-service
sur 5 reste impactée par les difficultés
d'approvisionnement et les Français
faut-il le reconnaître subissent la
lenteur de réaction du gouvernement face
au blocage des raffineries et une
nouvelle difficulté se présente
aujourd'hui en cette sortie de crise
c'est celle du prix des carburants avec
des hausses et parfois des prix
exorbitants vous le savez je le répète
dans beaucoup de territoires en France
le recours à la voiture est usuel est
nécessaire et même incontournable pour
des actusuels de la vie amener ses
enfants à l'école les amener leur
activité sportive et culturelles aller
voir des proches faire ses courses elle
est tout autant pour un certain nombre
de professions la voiture est un outil
de travail qui ne serait être remplacé
les aides à domicile ils infirmiers les
travailleurs indépendants ou tout
simplement les salariés
[Applaudissements]